If you've been wondering how to help the people of Gaza
without your money or resources falling into
the hands of people who use it to promote violence,
I would like to suggest doctors without borders.
It's an international organization that is focused on
helping citizens caught in crisis and in violence.
I think, especially if you're a Jewish American
like I am, it's really important to remember that
the dozens did not ask for this,
and they're having entire communities be wiped out.
That their citizens are just as worth protecting
as those in Israel.
Without a prolonged ceasefire and aid,
these people are being sentenced to death
for a crime that was committed by a select few.
A select few, mind you,
that will probably weather this
a lot better than the average family.
Hamas has the resources and the organization
to get out of dodge
in a way that the average family can't.
Don't believe
will destroy Hamas
by murdering a bunch of innocent people.
If you believe, like I do,
that Hamas wants the destruction of the Jewish people,
then we have to be so careful.
We have to hold on to our belief
in the sanctity of human life
and not let their hate infect us in turn.
Haven't always been able to articulate this well.
Don't believe civilians are collateral damage.
I can dismiss
stand with the Jewish community,
but I also stand with